i was 21 years old
and i was um
working as a bartender in san antonio at
dick's last resort and it was during the
daytime
and there were these three
30-something-year-old women sitting in
front of me
and uh
i was
one of them was flirting with me and i
just didn't at that age i didn't really
know what to say and so two of them left
and left one of the women
and i at 21 i had only ever flirted with
21 year olds so i was you know saying
those stupid things like uh
um
friends left i go oh your friends left
you alone huh and she goes
no i just stayed
and i go oh
i go you're not
you're not scared
and she goes
no
but you should be
and i was like
i was horny and scared at the same time
like one single tear came out of my dick
like pink uh
you know
and so she goes write down your number
on this piece of paper
and uh i'm picking you up tonight at
seven
so i go home
and i tell all my friends are about your
age dude and now they were they were
like whoa
what's going on you look excited
it's gonna be a great night and they go
what are you doing tonight i said i'm
gonna [ __ ] a grown-up
and they were like what i go yeah she
probably does dishes and goes grocery
shopping
and she's like a grown-up you know and i
was trying to put on grown-up clothes
beforehand like i must have changed
seven times before that date like is
this what a grown-up wears [ __ ] you know
and so
she pulls into my house into the
driveway
in a minivan
and my buddy looks out the window and he
goes
hey wolf
your mom's here
and i was like okay guys i was so
excited
i think i ran out to that van like it
was a play date i was like hey
mom said i could stay until 10 so
you know
and we get in the car
and um
you know i think we're gonna do grown-up
stuff so i said so what are we doing
dinner in a movie she goes no
i go we
are going dancing she goes no
i go what are we doing she goes i'm not
planning on leaving the van
and i was like
what
she goes is that a problem i go no
that's fine this time so we drive over
to this place called breckenridge park
which is in san antonio she pulls in
parks the minivan
and guys you know i like weird [ __ ] so
you know i like it when she said this to
me
she gets opens her car door and she goes
hey
help me move the car seats in the back
and i was like okay
[Laughter]
is that what's happening okay you know
and by the way man i know you're sitting
next to your dad but have you ever had
any milf type fantasies
cougar
that's a yes i'm gonna tell you
something right now
don't dude bad idea you're not ready for
it
guys under the age of 25 you're not
you're you're i can tell you your ego is
too fragile you're not ready to get into
bed with a grown woman you're not ready
to get into bed and do the move that you
know is the best move you got
and have her look you straight in the
face and go what the [ __ ] is that
it'll [ __ ] you up for the rest of your
life man i tell you what and the reason
i know that is because i was in the back
of this van with this woman and i was
not sexually advanced and it took me a
long time and i've said this before to
realize that the penis in the vagina are
not in the same place do you know what i
mean i i always forget that the the the
vagina is at the end of the cul-de-sac
do you know what i mean it's
it's on carpal tunnel lane you know what
i mean it's back there
and she actually said to me she looked
me right in the face and she goes
do you think that's where my vagina is
and i was like not anymore
and she said
lay down and i go okay
and uh i said what do you want me to do
she goes nothing i don't want you to
touch me or talk to me
i go what she goes all i need you to do
is just stay still and don't don't mess
this up for me
and she
this is the first person that's ever had
sex with me like she slapped me once she
was crying there was sweat i was like
what the [ __ ] is happening you know i
had no idea i had no idea at my age like
what is going on right now
you know i laid down and i had no shirt
on and there was a cheerio stuck to my
back and i was like snacks you know
why not just you got to play with your
environment you know what i'm saying
and but i had no idea what what the get
down was and i it was the first person
that i had sex with that knew how to
have sex
and knew how to do it by herself pretty
effectively you know and she went so
hard guys i'm not lying there was
i had rug burn this is the 90s people
still have rugs you know what i mean
it was i had rug burn here and she
literally
when she got off of me it was like a
like uh like some sort of olympic
dismount perfect landing
and she was just like ha and i was
sweaty i was scared i felt like i'd been
in fight
i am i'm in the back of this woman's van
and i was like do i at least get a capri
sun and some orange slices or what you
know
[Music]
[Music]
you